[MUSIC PLAYING]
GERARDO CAPIEL: Good
afternoon, everyone.
I'm Gerardo Capiel.
And I lead product management
for consumer payment products
here at Google.
And with me is my partner in
crime, Varouj Chitilian, who
leads the engineering side.
Payments are at the
heart of commerce.
If I want to buy a cup of
coffee, I've got to pay for it.
Payments are that link between
desire and fulfillment.
And that link is paramount
to making your apps grow
and your businesses thrive.
Unfortunately, that link
is also a major pain point
for many of you, particularly
on the mobile web
where conversion rates
are a third of what
they are on desktop.
We're constantly
thinking about how
to make payments easier,
faster, and safer.
Today, we're going
to be talking to you
about the foundation that
we've built with Android Pay,
and about how we're
expanding our APIs to enable
richer commerce experiences
both online and in-store.
Take it away, Varouj.
VAROUJ CHITILIAN:
The foundation,
as Gerardo mentioned,
is Android Pay,
our solution for fast and
secure mobile payments.
Over the past year, the team's
been working around the clock
to scale this
foundation globally.
And I'm so proud to say
that Android Pay is now
available in 10 markets.
But we're not stopping there.
In the coming months, we'll be
launching in Brazil, Canada,
Russia, Spain, and Taiwan.
So the momentum and the
traction is just incredible.
[APPLAUSE]
I'm personally very
excited about Brazil,
because it will be the first
Latin American country.
And I really want
to visit there.
We're not just strengthening
the foundation by expanding it.
We're strengthening it
also through partnerships.
One example of this is a
push provisioning APIs.
These APIs allow issuers
to embed core Android Pay
functionality directly
into their own apps.
So that for example in this
case, a Discover app user
can simply click the
link for Add Card.
This will provision their
card to their device.
And they can go
into a store, tap
and pay to purchase a good
without ever having installed
the Android Pay app.
The issuers that have
integrated the Push Provisioning
API to date have seen
phenomenal success.
And we're really
proud of this API.
We're also strengthening
this foundation
by partnering with
app developers.
We're doing this through
the Android Pay in-app APIs
that thousands of apps
have now integrated with.
And these APIs are bringing
seamless, streamlined, and very
smooth checkout to these
apps that are integrating.
For example, the jet.com app is
seeing a 3.5x conversion rate
increase just by implementing
these in-app APIs
in their checkout flow.
We're also expanding this
foundation to the mobile web.
And we're bringing Android
Pay to the mobile web.
And we're doing that through the
Payment Request APIs in Chrome.
So we're very
excited about that.
And recently "Washington Post"
integrated with these APIs.
And they've seen
very nice success
with a streamlined
and native experience
that they're seeing in their
mobile web checkout flow.
We're very excited
about all the momentum
we're seeing in
building this foundation
that we've built
over the past year.
Now I'd like to pass
it over to Gerardo
so he can talk about
how we're building
on top of this
foundation that we have
so we can expose our users to
even greater mobile payment
experiences.
Gerardo.
GERARDO CAPIEL: Thanks, Varouj.
Great.
So let's start with online.
As many of you know, having a
streamlined checkout experience
is critical for your
web sites to grow
and for your business to thrive.
We want to make
it easier for you
to make it easier for your users
to transact online, and not
have to deal with onerous forms.
And we're going to
do that two ways.
First, we're collaborating
with a major payment platforms.
Last year we
announced initiatives
with Visa and MasterCard.
And as you might have heard
in Sridhar's keynote earlier,
we're adding Paypal
to that list.
As we roll out each
of those integrations,
users will be able to
link either Visa Checkout,
Masterpass or PayPal to
their Android Pay account.
And they will enjoy a
streamlined authentication
and payment experience.
And the best part
is they don't have
to do any additional
work if they're already
accepting Visa Checkout,
Masterpass, or PayPal.
So let's take a look
at how that works.
We flip the phone, please?
Great.
All right.
So it's starting to get
hot out there already.
Summer is around the corner.
And I'm starting to
think about it's time
to spend some time
around the pool.
So what do I like to
have around the pool?
Well, margaritas,
that's for sure.
And so earlier today I went
and started looking around
for some margarita mix.
And I have some in my
shopping cart right here.
Skinny Williams-Sonoma
Margarita Mix.
Williams-Sonoma,
great e-commerce site.
And so I think I have
enough margarita mix.
And now I'm ready to check out.
So down here I see a
Visa Checkout button.
Now when I click
that button, voila.
I see the cards.
I'm already logged in.
And I see my Visa cards already.
I didn't have to enter in
my username or my password.
It's that simple.
And the best part is the finish.
I just supply my fingerprint.
And voila again.
I'm done.
Just a really
fantastic experience.
And like I said, the best part
is that Williams-Sonoma already
has Visa Checkout.
So when we roll out that
integration and Android Pay
users link their Visa Checkout
account to Android Pay,
they'll be ready to go.
Nothing else to do.
But we're not stopping there.
As you probably
heard earlier today,
our users have saved hundreds of
millions of payment instruments
to their Google account.
And they do that
when they're making
purchases on Google
Play, on YouTube,
or transacting in Chrome.
And the benefit of that is that
they get a simplified checkout
experience on future purchases.
It's really great experience.
So what if we could bring that
simplified checkout experience
to your apps and the
websites that you build?
Well, as hopefully you heard
in the earlier keynote,
today we announced the
Google payment API.
And when you implement
that API, your customers
will be able to
quickly check out
using any of the cards
in their Google account.
Just super simple.
And that's going to work, as
I said, in apps; on the web;
and as you'll see in
a bit, the Assistant.
So let's take a look at that.
So I'm going to pop over here.
And let's bring it back.
Great.
And I'm going to fire up
one of my favorite apps--
the Wish app.
And Wish has been
testing this API with us
over the last couple of months.
And so I was talking
about summer, the pool.
I need some pool toys.
I love this inflatable lounger.
But unfortunately, last year
I jumped off the diving board,
belly flopped onto the
lounger and popped it.
So I need another one.
So I have it in my shopping
cart already ready to go.
And if I see at the
bottom of the screen
there is a Pay
with Google button.
When I click that button, I
see the last card that I used.
But if I click further, I can
see all the cards in my Google
account, including those that
I added through Android Pay.
Hit Continue.
And voila again.
Transaction is complete.
[APPLAUSE]
It's really fantastic.
Super simple.
Love it.
So in the next few
months we're going
to be piloting
the Google Payment
API with a number of
leading merchants and apps.
And we want all of you to
be able to pilot this app
and implement it.
And to accelerate
that process, we're
partnering with leading payment
processors such as Braintree,
and Stripe, Invantive,
ACI, Addion, First
Data, and Worldpay.
We're really excited to see
what you all do with the API,
and what fantastic
conversion rates you get.
Soon, we're going to be
uploading our developer
documentation.
And in the meantime, I
encourage you all to go
to
developers.google.com/payments
and register to get
notifications of when
the developer documentation is
available so you can get going.
Now as I've mentioned, this
also works on websites.
So tomorrow morning I
would encourage you all
to go get a cup of
coffee free on us.
You don't have to pay for it.
And go to the Future of Web
Payments session on Stage 6
at 8:30 AM.
But if you can't
get up that early--
and I'll be up that
early, I'll be there--
we have office hours
at 9:30 AM tomorrow
and at Friday at 11:30 AM.
Hope to see you all there.
So now that you've
seen how easy it
is to do transactions
on the web and in apps,
let's talk about how
seamless transactions can
be in the Assistant.
So I hope a lot of you here in
the crowd own a Google Home.
And if you do, you've
hopefully had the opportunity
to buy everyday essentials
from over 50 merchants,
including Whole
Foods and Walgreens.
Soon, we're going to be
adding even more merchants who
have integrated with our
Google Shopping APIs.
But we're taking it
one step further.
We're also going to enable
you all to build purchase
actions with the Assistant.
And in case you didn't see
it at the last session,
here's how it works.
So the user simply says,
I want to talk to Panera.
They specify what
they want to order.
Panera might even
suggest some drinks
that they might want
to go with that order.
And then the user is able to
complete the transaction using
the cards in their
Google account,
and authenticate with
their fingerprint.
That simple.
Fantastic experience.
So now you see how we're
making the Assistant an even
greater platform for commerce.
VAROUJ CHITILIAN: Wow, Gerardo.
That was super cool.
GERARDO CAPIEL: It is.
VAROUJ CHITILIAN:
How about we use
the Assistant to order some
Panera for after the session?
GERARDO CAPIEL: OK.
But let me pay you
back for dinner.
I don't want it
to be just on you.
And what I can do
is I'll send you
some money using our new
Gmail Send Money function.
VAROUJ CHITILIAN: Nah.
Everyone's seen
that feature before.
How about you pay, and I'll show
the audience something really
cool that no one
has seen before.
GERARDO CAPIEL: OK.
VAROUJ CHITILIAN: Who wants
to see something super cool?
Come on, let's hear it.
[CHEERING]
All right.
So let's move to Cast One.
There you go.
OK.
Google.
Send $10 to Gerardo for dinner.
Yes.
[APPLAUSE]
VAROUJ CHITILIAN: Whoo!
Awesome.
GERARDO CAPIEL: We need--
VAROUJ CHITILIAN: I think
you have to go back a slide.
Let's go back two slides.
GERARDO CAPIEL: So-- thank you.
As you saw, we're adding
P2P to the Assistant.
And it will leverage the debit
cards in your Google account
to send money to
friends and others.
And we're just getting started.
We plan to soon onboard
other P2P providers.
Varouj.
VAROUJ CHITILIAN: So Gerardo is
showing some really cool stuff
that we're working on in mobile
payments in the online space.
We all know that 85% of commerce
still happens in in-stores.
So I'd like to talk
to you a bit about how
we're enhancing our
merchant-facing APIs to give
your customers a better
in-store experience.
At the center of
it all is loyalty.
Loyalty is the
connection between you--
the merchant, and
your customers--
the user.
And we'd like to help you
with loyalty in three ways.
We'd like to help you
one, with enrollment.
So helping expose your loyalty
programs to Android Pay users
and signing them up.
Two, with engagement.
Once the Android Pay user has
your loyalty card associated
in their Android
Pay account, being
able to push offers to them
that are relevant to them,
personalized to them.
And three, we'd like to help
you with easy redemption
and earning of loyalty
points and offers
so that just with
a simple NFC tap--
what we call a smart tap--
the user with Android Pay can
transmit loyalty and offer
information just as
easily as they paid today
with Android Pay.
So let's look at each of
these three individually.
So say I'm an Android Pay user.
And I need to go to Walgreens
to pick up some shampoo.
It's for my daughter, of course.
So Android Pay will send
the following notification.
Says, Faster checkout
at Walgreens.
Add your balance rewards to
Android Pay for an easier way
to save.
Balance Rewards is a loyalty
program for Walgreens.
And Walgreens has implemented
our Smart Tap technology
at their payment terminals.
So with one tap on
this notification,
and a few things in
the Android Pay app,
we can easily sign
up the Android Pay
user for the Walgreens Balance
Rewards loyalty program.
So super exciting.
But we've taken
it a step further.
Say I'm a Balance
Rewards member.
And I'm an Android Pay user.
But I haven't connected
my Balance Rewards card
to my Android Pay.
So let's move to the demo.
This is cast 2.
The second cast.
View cast to 1.
Oh.
There we go.
Great.
Oh, that's the
wrong one, actually.
I tried some magic here.
Actually, I really
need to be casted.
There we go.
Oh, there we go.
Perfect.
Actually, these are
demo slides, I guess.
Oh, perfect.
I think it's the device.
All right.
So we're on cast 2 now.
So now I'm buying a bag of nuts.
And I have to remember
my phone number here.
I think it was that landline
that I had four years ago.
I think it was.
OK.
Now I tap.
So now I have tapped to pay.
But I've entered my loyalty
information manually.
Wouldn't it be magical
if I was somehow
told that I can now add
this Balance Rewards
card that I entered manually
into Android Pay automatically?
Wow.
That's pretty cool.
We just got a notification
from Android Pay.
And with a single
click in the app,
we can now save this
Balance Rewards card
that I used manually
into Android Pay
so that on subsequent visits,
I don't have to actually punch
in my phone number on
the payment terminal
and remember what my number
was on that landline years ago.
So a second pillar of
loyalty, and the second area
we'd like to help you
with, is engagement.
How do you engage with
that customer that
saved your loyalty
card in Android Pay
and push them offers
so that they'll
come back to your store?
For this we have another
demo with a Panera app.
And the Panera loyalty
program is actually
called the My Panera program.
So if you can go to--
there we go.
So I'm going to go
into the Panera app--
Panera app.
Sorry.
And I'm going to
click on Rewards.
There you go.
And what I'll do is I'll save
my My Panera card to Android Pay
by this one click
of this button.
Great.
So my My Panera loyalty card
is now saved to Android Pay.
Now if I go into Android Pay, I
see the My Panera loyalty card,
which is really cool.
When I click into
it, we'll actually
see a rich set of offers
associated with my My Panera
card.
What's even cooler is if
I'm walking by a Panera,
I will actually get a
GeoNotification that tells me
I have offers available to be
redeemed at the Panera store.
So this is a great way in
which to engage your customers
after they've linked their
loyalty program into Android
Pay.
And these new card-linked
offer APIs are now available.
And you guys can
take a look at them
at
developers.google.com/payments.
So now let's move
to the last part--
the last feature that we'd
like to help you with.
And that's to redeem loyalty
and offers at the store.
So I mentioned about Smart Tap.
We're very excited to announce
that Smart Tap is also
rolling out in
Singapore with NTUC
Link, our first
international partner.
But more than that, we're happy
to announce that Smart Tap will
be available to
businesses of all sizes,
including small and
medium-sized businesses.
And in order to do that, we've
partnered with Clover, a First
Data company.
I'm sure you've all seen the
slick point-of-sale and payment
terminals at your local
restaurant and cafes.
But the Clover terminals now
support Smart Tap technologies
to allow for easy redemption
of loyalty and offers.
So I'd like to invite John
Beatty, the CEO of Clover,
to come up and say a few
words about the collaboration.
Please give him a hearty
round of applause.
JOHN BEATTY: Thanks, Varouj.
So we at Clover are huge fans
of what Varouj and Gerardo are
doing here to really push
the boundaries in commerce
and consumer
experiences in commerce.
So let's give these guys a hand.
[APPLAUSE]
And it dovetails perfectly
with Clover's role.
So Clover's mission is to
enable innovation in commerce
on the merchant side.
Now we do this in two ways.
We provide open platforms in
point-of-sale and payments
to developers, and then also
through our parent company,
First Data, one of the world's
leading payment technology
companies.
We provide broad
distribution capabilities
to our vast array of
merchants, both in the US
and in many, many
countries worldwide.
Now we'll be supporting
Smart Tap in two ways.
First, in our Open
Payments platform.
This allows these devices here
that I'll demo here in a moment
to be able to do Smart
Tap interactions.
And so we're also
happy to announce
that two of our partners--
ShopKeep and Bypass Mobile--
will be building Smart
Tap-enabled experiences
through the Clover platform.
Secondly, the Clover customer
engagement suite of products--
through that suite
of products we'll
be enabling Smart Tap
technology to a vast array
of our small
businesses in the US.
We've shipped over
500,000 devices
to small businesses in the US.
And through this,
consumers and merchants
will have some fantastic
user experiences.
Now, there's three things about
Smart Tap that I really like.
First is simplicity.
It doesn't get
simpler than tapping
to earn, redeem, and pay.
It could hardly be simpler.
Second, it drives real
value for merchants.
When a customer enrolls
through Smart Tap, what
the merchant will be able to
do is push offers and rewards
directly into Android
Pay for those consumers.
They can also send
offers if say, you
have a lapsed
customer, and you want
to incent them to come
back to your store.
And it's really a
marketing technology
that I personally want.
It's both convenient,
and it's in context.
So lastly, it also
does one other thing,
which is it enables all
sorts of other innovation.
You can imagine a scenario
where you buy something online.
It could be on the mobile web.
It could be in a native app.
And say you buy it online.
And then you want to
pick it up in store.
You could save to Android
Pay, come in, and then tap
to present proof of purchase.
There's many, many other things
that we've been thinking about
in online to offline
commerce and offline
to online commerce that
are really enabled by this.
So if you need to build
anything that touches consumers
on the other side of the counter
with merchant technology,
please check us out.
clover.com/developers.
Back to you, Varouj.
VAROUJ CHITILIAN: All right.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, John.
At this point, I know two things
for certain about every member
of the audience here.
One, everyone could use a snack.
Right?
And number two, everyone
wants to check out
some of these loyalty
features in Android Pay
that we've been talking about.
Of course, right?
So we've got something
special for you.
We've created a game
called Tap for Treats
around I/O. All you have to
do is download the I/O loyalty
card from [INAUDIBLE]
URL or from the I/O app.
And you have to find
the Clover Smart
Tap terminals around the venue.
And if you find all
five of these terminals,
you will get a limited
edition Android
robot that looks like me.
No.
Just kidding.
Limited edition Android Paybot
that's not sold in stores.
So highly encourage
you to do that.
And I'd like to see if John
could show us how the Smart
Tap works on a Clover terminal.
We have one right here.
JOHN BEATTY: Sure.
So what I have here is my phone
with a Tap for Treats loyalty
card here.
Here I have a Clover Mini, which
is a fantastic customer-facing
payment device.
Happens to be based
on Clover OS use AOSP.
And then on this side is
our merchant-facing device.
So what I'm going to do is
I'm just going to take this.
I'm simply going
to hold this here.
I'm gonna tap.
Now you'll see here that
it welcomes me by name.
It says, Welcome to
Google I/O 2017, John.
Now one extra thing--
and this is another thing
I forgot to mention that I
love about Smart Tap-- is
it enables additional
personalization
at the point of sale.
So over here on
the merchant side--
this is still a prototype.
And we'll certainly
improve this.
But it has my name here.
You can imagine it can do things
like pull up my previous order.
The merchant can
greet me by name,
ask me if I want my usual.
And so I'll go ahead
here, and I'm just
going to check out
just real quick here.
And then right here
you'll be able to see
if I just refresh this that now
I have my extra loyalty point.
VAROUJ CHITILIAN: And
so John gets a treat.
JOHN BEATTY: Ah!
VAROUJ CHITILIAN: This is
a shave ice from Powder.
And it's a Smart Tap terminal
right here on Porch 1.
So thank you very much, John.
JOHN BEATTY: Wonderful.
Hey.
Thanks, everyone.
All right.
Thanks, Varouj.
VAROUJ CHITILIAN:
Gerardo, back to you.
GERARDO CAPIEL: So cool.
So hopefully, well, John's
getting a real taste.
But hopefully you
all have gotten
a taste of how we're
making payments
faster, easier, and safer.
You've heard how
we're collaborating
with the major payment
platforms like Visa, MasterCard,
and Paypal; how we're scaling
our solution by enabling users
to pay with the cards
in their Google account;
and how we're helping
merchants generate
loyalty among their customers
through our expanded APIs.
We can't do all this
innovation by ourselves.
We need all of you
to participate.
And we thank you
for your support.
We look forward to
working with you
between now and the
next I/O. And just
to wrap up with
some final points,
I'm going to turn
it back to Varouj.
VAROUJ CHITILIAN: All right.
So if you have any questions
about any of the features
you've seen or any of the
demos that you've seen,
please go to
developers.google.com/payments
and get information about
everything you've seen today.
Also, these are the
listings for our office
hours and our codelab.
So please drop by so we can give
you some hands-on experience
with some of this technology.
I'd also like to
direct you to two
sessions with related content.
One is for Android
developers called
Improved Sign-in, Payment
and Data Entry in your Apps.
And one is for Chrome
developers called Web Payments,
Making it Easy for
Users to Give You Money.
So thank you very much
for your attention.
And go out and tap for treats.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]